one of the things that worries me is
that people say oh now that I could get
arrested anytime I let my child play
outside or walk to school I won't do it
and that's the opposite of what
free-range kids is about free-range kids
is about getting so many kids outside
that it doesn't seem strange to see a
child playing in the park
hi I'm Nicolas booth recent TV and today
we're talking with Leonor scan Daisy
she's the proprietress and doyenne of
free-range kids a must read blog and
website which is featured at reason.com
as well as a creator syndicate and other
places around the web Leonor thanks for
joining us thank you for calling me
adore yes very great perfect so talk a
little you I mean what you do is you
track the insane ways that parents treat
their kids and also increasingly kind of
public authorities treat parents who
they say are negligent about their kids
what are some what are some big stories
that we should be talking about well I'm
gonna give you one that I think it's
kind of classic a mom in New Jersey
upscale neighborhood had to run an
errand and she left her 18 month old son
asleep in the car for everyone agrees 5
to 10 minutes in the parking lot of an
upscale mall so upscale that they had
guards driving around guard sees the
child in the car I guess he has no
authority whatsoever himself immediately
calls 911 and they arrested the mom and
she was found guilty of child abuse and
negligence and put on what New Jersey
has which i think is a terrible idea
which is a child abuse registry so if
she wanted to get a job as a teacher
daycare worker the lady who slings hash
at the cafeteria forget it
so she appealed this which I would too
and there was a three-judge panel and
they unanimously found her guilty again
and the reason they gave in their
written statement was that they they
didn't even have to list quote the
Horrible's not a word but they used it
the Horrible's that could have attended
this child so what they were saying is
first of all they could even come up
with what they were thinking of just the
idea that something bad could happen was
reason enough to make this woman a
guilty child abuser
so we're arresting a mom for making a
rational decision about her own child in
her own neighborhood and saying because
something bad could have happened she's
guilty well couldn't something bad
happen in your home don't people fall
downstairs where where does that case
stand now is oh what's really exciting
for me is that it's going to the Supreme
Court in New Jersey and if so I think
it's the first case of letting a kid
wait in a car that's going to any state
Supreme Court what is the
we've heard various stories over the
years of kids dying in cars all of those
types of stuff so what you know what is
driving this you know particularly where
the leaving a kid in a car I think
anybody who's over the age of about 40
can remember being you know staying in a
car probably without seatbelts on why
your mom or your dad ran into the store
for something when did this become you
know just a horrible horrible thing to
do to your kid there was an article
written in the Washington Post about
five years ago that want a fuel at
surprise talking about the agony which
everybody could empathize with of
parents who had forgotten their kids in
the car and that generally happens if
you're gonna drop off the kids normally
but I take them today because you're
going to the dentist and my child falls
asleep in the backseat and the car seat
I don't see the kid I don't hear the kid
I'm on automatic pilot I go into work I
turn off the car I go in and I come back
on and there's the tragedy what we don't
realize is that that's the way the vast
majority of kids who do die in cars
expire is when they're forgotten there
for literally hours but somehow and this
is something that I see across the board
in parenting issues is we've decided
that even a second of a child alone is
the same as five hours of the child
alone and at my blog I hear from all the
moms who have been arrested for letting
their kids wait five or ten minutes in
the car and I've even heard from mom
saying that when they were they put
their kids in the car after they all
went to the grocery and they're
returning the grocery cart and when they
get back to the car somebody is
screaming at them how dare you leave
your children alone don't you realize
that children die that way and I want to
say don't you realize children don't die
that way I can't find any story of a
child dying within the course of a five
or ten-minute errand while the mom was
picking up the pizza it doesn't happen
that way but we're arresting moms for
what are what are other locations or
kind of set pieces or motifs that we see
and in child endangerment hysteria
people think that any time you're not
directly supervising your child if
they're outside they are in danger and
so we've heard a couple stories this
summer one of them went viral from your
site of a mom who let her child play in
the park for three days in a row and
some busybody said where is your mother
the child was nine had a cellphone could
call her mom
her mom was working and so the busybody
I think part of the problem is that we
all have phones it was so easy for her
to call 911 be the hero and slash you
know Good Samaritan which I think a Good
Samaritan says Oh your mom's out here
let me know if you need anything can I
help you you know if you scrape yourself
I've got band-aids that's a good
Samaritan calling 9-1-1 is the KGB
it's like Eastern Europe so the police
come and once again it's that same thing
because something bad could have
happened to this child even though it
was so unlikely in a popular park with
tons of children around with busy bodies
roaming the place the mother was
arrested thrown into jail and the child
was taken from her for 17 days yeah and
and that's preferable to letting the kid
play in a safe Park one of the things
that worries me is that people say oh
now that I could get arrested anytime I
let my child play outside or walk to
school I won't do it and that's the
opposite of what free-range kids is
about free-range kids is about getting
so many kids outside that it doesn't
seem strange to see a child playing in
the park always have all the kids kind
of shouting I'm Spartacus it's like
having all the kids saying not at 90 and
playing a huge game of tag like we used
to do yeah
the reason I think that we are hearing
about the the busybodies is that first
of all people have been told over and
over on the news and even on flashing
signs on the highway if you see a child
alone immediately report them so they
really come to believe that any time a
child is alone they are in danger of
being kidnapped and of course if you
turn on the TV that's the story that we
hear from wherever it happens anywhere
in the world because that's the story
that sells so parents are and and
everybody has a wrong idea of how
frequent it is that kids are hurt by
stranger stranger danger is the least
way that kids are ever hurt and kids do
very well and I mean just for the I mean
for the record basically across the
board on every index of flourishing in
America kids are safer healthier longer
lived happier right one one of the
reasons one of the things I try to to
press on free range kids is this this
hysteria about child danger is so
ungrateful I mean we are so lucky to be
raising our kids who me at this era in
history when everything from infant
mortality to kidnapping and rape and
murder they're all down at some
people say oh crime is down because we
keep our children inside and now we care
and I'm like well crime is down against
the dolt women adult men houses burglary
car car theft they're all down and we're
not keeping all those things inside so
you just have to accept the fact that
crime is down to the rate it was in 1963
before color television when gas was
twenty nine cents a gallon so there's
some huge disconnect between the desire
to save kids from being outside and the
fact that kids are safer than ever
outside so what about the authorities
and this because it would seem you know
I was surprised when you were talking
about the appellate court I thought you
were gonna say the appellate court three
judges instead of one said what the hell
was going on here instead they they not
you know pump it up to the next level so
what's going on with authorities is this
just fear of lawsuits or do they have
they are they leading the charge or are
they they captivated by these fears I
think that when you live in a society
where you're breathing in this fear on a
daily basis your cops your courts your
juries are not immune to it either and I
think when a cop is called first of all
I I'm pretty sure they're obligated to
come as opposed to saying why did you
call me when the mom gets there in five
or ten minutes and if she's not there
then I'll come they're not allowed to
say that so they come and then they have
to have something to do and sometimes
there's this such I don't know if it's
protocol that's required or just an
inflated sense of drama but I was gonna
tell you another story about a mom left
her kid in the car baby
for four minutes everybody agrees it was
four minutes she was in the store
somebody outside a guy came in and said
there's a baby in the car whose baby is
it this mom said it's mine she was in
line to check out she proceeded to check
out that infuriated him he called the
cops the cops later the lady wasn't
there by the time they got there so they
went to her house and with them they
brought a team of paramedics and the
paramedics checked out the child and
guess what having slept through this
four minute errand the child turned out
to be thank God how do you like that
fine but when we have not only the cops
there but also this idea that the child
was in such grave danger in four minutes
I mean if if people died in four minutes
in cars we would all be dead the first
time we're in
in a traffic jam who hate or waiting in
the driveway for a dad to come out with
his coat so what do you think where is
the fear coming from you know a and and
then what's the best way to kind of keep
it at bay within ourselves because I
think all parents as well anybody who
looks at kids like you you know you get
really nervous and also if you have a
society that's selling you I just have
to tell you Mike there's some products
out there that just sort of make obvious
that we're supposed to be afraid all the
time there's a now a child carrier that
goes up to 80 pounds okay and it's not
further disabled which I could
understand is for children who quit can
walk but choose not to which I'd be
really proud if I had that kid um
there's a product you can buy called
tooth prince which is you make an
impression of your children's teeth and
you've swab their cheeks for their DNA
so that when their body is found but
unidentifiable because it's been so
mangled lucky you you have this tooth
print thing there so when you're
breathing in this kind of fear on a
daily basis everybody gets infected the
other thing that I've seen recently that
I'm very excited about is something I
call the free-range kids project that
was just done for the first time in an
entire grammar school in Menlo Park
which is headquarters of a lot of
Silicon Valley companies and what it was
is all the teachers told all their kids
that they could choose something that
they wanted to do that they felt they
were ready to do that they hadn't done
yet
walk the dog take your bike to school
make dinner and children from
kindergarten up to fifth grade chose
projects out of the seven hundred kids
220 Didem and I had the parents fill out
a little form what are you afraid of
beforehand and then how did it go
afterwards and the results were so
spectacular for instance one family
hadn't let their kid ever ride his bike
to school and that's what he was
desperate to do fourth grader so when
that's what he said I really want to do
this they said no there's a street you'd
have to cross it's busy how about we let
you ride your bike to your friend's
house on Saturday that's the compromise
that they finally did they'd never let
him ride anywhere by himself he did it
on Saturday he came back elated proud
they are proud - this breaks the fear
you're so proud of your kid and they're
flushed and they're happy and they're
hungry and they're burbling
and so that was Saturday and Tuesday
morning the dad said to the mom and it
was the dad in this case who had been
more overprotective why don't we just
let him ride to school and he did that
for the rest of the year and this
happened over and over again all you
need is a little push once you see your
kid do something you did as a child it's
very easy to let go of the fear because
it was superimposed and reality comes
bursting through all right well we'll
leave it there Thank You Lenore skin' AZ
Lenore is the proprietress of free range
kids she also blogs at reason.com and
her column for creator syndicate shows
up in newspapers and websites around the
country and around the world the North
thanks so much for talking to us
thanks for recent TV I'm Nikolas